so House Democrats yesterday as we
discussed they were about to do release
the resolution to formalize the
impeachment inquiry into Donald Trump so
understand that so far they've been pre
interviewing witnesses in private in
accordance with the law by the way as I
will shortly remind you in the next
segment a very interesting segment up
coming this is now an impeachment
inquiry resolution the House is expected
to vote on it Thursday and it outlines
the process that is going to be taking
place to inquire about whether Donald
Trump should be impeached by the House
of Representatives ultimately
subsequently to be voted on by the
Senate what does the resolution say well
for starters at its conclusion if the
inquiry is going to create a public
report of their findings and this is
important in the sense that it is one of
the areas that has been heavily
criticized by Republicans that
everything is happening quote in secret
well in reality nothing has actually
happened yet there's just been pre
interviewing of witnesses but at the
conclusion of this inquiry there will be
a public report that is going to be
issued now importantly to Donald Trump
who as you may know has been complaining
about there's no due process I'm not
getting any due process here even though
we simply didn't get to that point yet
nothing wrong has happened so far the
resolution outlines the due process that
Donald Trump is going to get and you can
make the argument that it's actually
generous to Donald Trump the resolution
outlines some new due process rights for
the President of the United States
overall in a sort of balanced sober
rational analysis there's really nothing
controversial in the resolution
whatsoever it's very similar to the
process that was employed during Bill
Clinton's impeachment back in 1998 the
difference being that with Bill Clinton
there was this Independent Counsel
report remember this guy Ken Starr who
was brought in to investigate Bill
Clinton there was a report which came
which present was presented to the House
committees involved by the Independent
Counsel specifically to the
committing this time it's a little bit
different the house itself will be doing
the investigating and it will be the
entity the Judiciary Committee will be
the entity issuing the full report
rather than receiving it from a special
prosecutor independent prosecutor so now
the rubber is sort of going to start
meeting the road and what I mean by that
is we're going to see very quickly if
Republicans and Donald Trump settle down
over there are no guidelines and no due
process because the resolution gives
them everything that they've been asking
for now of course there's a chance call
me a skeptic call me a cynic there's a
chance that it wasn't really about
process and guidelines all along it was
just something that Republicans and
Trump grasped onto like a last desperate
straw to try to stop what it is that is
going on but in any case if we go by
what they've said Republicans have been
asking for their own subpoena power to
bring in witnesses they are being given
that by this resolution Donald Trump has
been asking or demanding or complaining
about not having due process he is
getting that we have very clear
guidelines here for what this process is
going to look like and what the
deliverable is going to be deliverable
by the way doesn't have to be a bad word
although when Donald Trump uses it it
often alludes to corruption the
deliverable in this case will be a
report a public report summarizing the
impeachment inquiry Trump wanted due
process and the resolution gives him
that and it's really important to
remember that the resolution also by the
way outlines and this is where it starts
to get very interesting the resolution
outlines the possibility of public
hearings which would be just endlessly
fascinating Congressman Jim McGovern
whose Democrat from Massachusetts
chairman of the Rules Committee he
released the resolution yesterday
afternoon I actually bumped into Jim
McGovern over the weekend in Northampton
Massachusetts at the world-famous
Haymarket Cafe very exciting moment for
me
he clearly forgot who I was and had no
recollection of having met me
but regardless Jim McGovern releasing
for us yesterday the resolution so
prepare yourselves now for just a new
wave of bad
arguments from Republicans about how
this is still unfair how it's still a
witch-hunt how it is still a terrible
unfair example of presidential
harassment and also expect the White
House to again start moving the bar to
come up with new excuses for why they
are going to be ignoring and directing
everyone under their purview to ignore
all subpoenas because before it was
there's no guidelines there's no due
process it's an open-ended secret thing
that's going on now we've been told here
are the guidelines here is the due
process and there will be a public
report after possibly public hearings
they will come up with something new to
justify in their minds and in the minds
of their supporters why they are going
to not cooperate with this inquiry what
I am most looking forward to is that in
the resolution this is just great it
mentions 45 minutes of uninterrupted
questioning of witnesses by each side
Democrats would get 45 minutes and then
Republicans would get 45 minutes with
witnesses in public testimony if you've
watched congressional testimony before
you probably remember that before there
is even a prelude and one question asked
they're low on time because often times
each member of the House will get five
minutes it's just not enough time still
sometimes there are fireworks but it is
not enough time 45 minutes of
uninterrupted questioning of a single
witness the fireworks and the implosions
that we could see in 45 minutes of
straight questioning could be absolutely
glorious and I am very very much looking
forward to it and this may be it maybe
in the end Republicans shooting
themselves in the foot by demanding
transparency because now they have it
and it doesn't look like it's the type
of transparency that is going to be
particularly good for the narrative that
they have been crafting more upcoming on
this I am sure I want to hear from you
how do you think the vote will go in the
house well the most straightforward
prediction is just a party line a
straight party-line vote and what do you
expect if and when these public
impeachment inquiry hearings actually
get going